no republicans generally republicans
have gotten weak i'll give you an
example i
i said they're weak they're timid
they're spineless they're visionless
i said that for a long time
you know we recently lost john lewis i
have nothing politically that i agree
with john lewis except
that and the first day in atlanta i got
a call to my radio show from then mayor
maynard jackson but i got to know joseph
lowery
the sclc they all come on my program the
mayor would come on my program
hosea williams was my favorite guest
ever really
close friend of martin luther king jr
john lewis andy young and i don't think
andy liked me much but
but all these guys i i knew when i got
to know their story and it was one of
great courage and conviction
and and if you look at selma to
montgomery if you look at
fire hoses and dogs and i learned this
lesson
you see the the peaceful protests of
that time
they helped make this a more perfect
union
they put it all on the line here's an
interesting side note to
this you know because we watched the
eulogy with obama
this uh the eulogy obama gave it at the
john lewis
uh remembrance and all the politics that
he brought up which i
found outrageous out just it was a
political speech
it was it was awful yeah but he talked
about the john lewis extension of the
voting rights act
and i'm thinking well hang on a second
because the guy that's leading your
ticket
joe biden the ever corrupt ever
forgetful
ever out of it joe biden uh
well joe biden says his mentor and his
dear friend was robert byrd
the former klansmen by the way hillary
said it
bill said it schumer said it pelosi said
it
so the talk so so former president obama
is talking about these historic bills
that john lewis
absolutely along with so many others
bravely fought for
and made us a more perfect union not
perfect we still have a long way to go
but
so and yet they're talking about the act
but the guy that's running actually
supported
the guy that filibustered that historic
legislation
people don't know and this drives me
nuts every two years every four years
what do they say about republicans it's
every election cycle
republicans are racist sexist misogynist
homophobic xenophobic islamophobic
uh they want dirty air and water a paul
ryan look alike it'll probably be a
donald trump look-alike this year
is going to take granny in a wheelchair
after she's only eaten dog or cat food
for a year
and throw her over the cliff in the
wheelchair that's
every two and four years it is atrocious
i went through unhannity this week a
history of how this happens every two
and four years
well the civil rights act lyndon johnson
needed
and the voting rights act 80 percent
republicans
80 percent republican of the house and
senate
and then you have the mentor of
their democratic presidential candidate
praising the guy that filibustered that
bill i mean that's madness to me
that's the guy that when integration was
coming up talked about
uh uh kids and integration of school
as a racial jungle that he was worried
about
what donald trump says this is an actual
quote this is an actual quote so i think
a lot of people are waking up to this
and i think that's partly because
suddenly well suddenly people can see
the clips online where in the old days
you couldn't really see the clips right
what do you think happened to the
republicans or to the gop
or to conservatives that let this thing
get
so confused that the reality of the
history
compared to the way it's it's portrayed
is that purely just a media concoction
or
do the republicans have some blame there
themselves no republicans
generally republicans have gotten weak
i'll give you an example i i said
they're weak they're timid they're
spineless they're visionless i said that
for a long time
when republicans finally elected
when we finally got a republican
president that would repeal and replace
obamacare
where were the republicans that voted 60
some odd times to repeal and replace
they disappeared and they never even had
an alternative in place i had an
alternative
you know either patient power a cato
institute book by
by musgrave and goodman that i've read
years ago or
a doctor that i often put on my show dr
josh umber who who created
in wichita kansas a healthcare
cooperative it's only 50 bucks a month
24
7 concierge care he negotiates directly
with pharmaceutical companies
guess what 50 bucks a month for an adult
10 bucks a month for a child
doctor available 24 7. you walk out with
the medicines at a 90
95 reduce rate you add that with a
catastrophic plan if god forbid you have
a heart attack cancer or a bad accident
they were all they weren't ready and
then the senators
actually voted republican senator seven
of them
voted for the exact same bill they had
voted for two years
that they voted on two years prior just
a straight repeal bill
now when it meant something it didn't
mean anything so i'm angry at them for
that now
in terms of republicans allowing this
this false narrative to go forward
i do it every election year dave i i
show the same clips
there's a 1998 missouri radio ad i went
through this this week if you like
republicans
you know a cross is gonna burn or the
james bird ad in 2000
that that said it's like my father was
killed all over again
because george bush didn't support hate
crime legislation
uh with this horrific dragging death of
this innocent man
james byrd but george bush did support
the death penalty
so he wanted the guy dead you know for
that crime for that inhumanity that evil
and you know or al gore goes before a
predominantly african-american audience
and he's
he changes his tone his pitch his
cadence it's
to me it's like really tries to sound
like he's a preacher in a
a predominantly african-american church
republicans have the wrong
agenda for african-americans they don't
even want to count you in the census
or hillary clinton same thing prominent
predominantly african-american audience
i don't feel no ways tired i mean what
is this
she's got hot sauce sean she's got hot
sauce in her bag don't forget that
oh i do remember that yes indeed indeed
um or they're gonna put you all back in
chains
so this is the playbook i told everybody
as i started the year and before i went
on vacation at the end of last year
it's coming they will do it it's the
playbook
dirty air dirty water racist sexist
massage and straight on through that's
what frustrates me about mitt romney
mitt romney the very same people he's
now embracing
are the very same people that said he
was a racist and a sexist and a
misogynist
so it's and it's frustrating the same
people he was running he had he had
binders full of women they said he's a
misogynist now now he's the hero
so is that binders by the way were
women's women's resumes so we could hire
them
okay jeez sorry i have a resume
that doesn't make it into the tweets
though you know twitter it's short so
you're gonna you gotta pick it up i
don't know
i'm in twitter twitter prison if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about the media instead of
non-stop yelling check out our media
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out the full episode playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell